there was a good period of time where
confident
talented powerful men walked around with
curly hair
and we're going to bring it back
[Music]
the male prone was popular like in the
70s and the 80s and it's about to become
super popular in 2015. i'm a big k-pop
fan
a lot of those guys they get perms a
friend asked you to do something you do
it but
the male perm is not here to stay the
male perm
is coming back the steps of getting a
perm are we would first
shampoo the hair and get it clean and
then we would set the hair
in rollers and then we would determine
whether we would just set it going back
or spiral perm when i saw my aunt doris
get her perm i
said to myself one day i want to grow up
and get my aunt doris's hair cut
how does it look i mean
i feel like a badass you look like a
badass okay
and then we would apply the perm
solution and we would let that sit in
and the perm solution is
the acid cinnamon then we would be using
the alkaline which is the neutralizer
which will neutralize it and bring the
ph
back in the hair
there we go all right
can i open open oh my god
surprise
nope one time with my eyes no
oh my god i look like a
55
i'm gonna bring this back people will
love it we're gonna go crash this party
and see what people think of our perms
[Music]
it feels like you didn't even get a perm
it feels like
it feels like you're what fabio should
have been
i'm getting a perm right now the mail
perms back
[Music]
you